there's the scene above ground and the  scene below ground and the scene above  ground is what's going on and the  dialogue and them sitting around this  table and talking I don't consider the  comparison and insult underneath it it's  like the suspense is a rubber band  and I'm just stretching it and  stretching it and stretching and see how  far it can stretch now normally in a  situation when you do a movie you try to  make your scenes as compact as possible  so there's not air and you don't wear  out your welcome with the audience but  under this method as long as that rubber  band can stretch the longer the scene  can hold the more suspenseful it is that  scene is more suspenseful at 22 minutes  and would be at eight so you want to  just stretch it until the rubber band  breaks